[MUSIC PLAYING]
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: Thank
you Andrei and Irina
for joining us here today.
At Google, we talk a
lot about the user.
I spent two and a half years
in Mountain View as a PM
on couple of different products.
And whenever I talked
about the user,
I would look at a dashboard.
And that dashboard would have
various numbers and graphs
of the number of users in
different countries, the level
of engagement that they had on
a day to day or week to week
basis.
And that was my touch point.
But I think why I'm so
grateful that you're
joining us here today is that
you represent the user in it's
so much more tangible sense.
You are journalists
on the front lines
of a super important
issue for Google.
Our mission is to organize
the world's information,
make it accessible and useful.
And that is what
you do every day.
You organize information on
very sensitive, very challenging
topics, and you make it
accessible and useful
to the world.
And so my hope
today is that we can
get into what that process looks
like, how technology has helped
and hindered, and what
the folks in this room who
care about these issues can do
to contribute going forward.
To begin with, maybe if you're
comfortable just sharing
a little bit about your
backgrounds, the work
you do, and the places
that you do it in.
ANDREI SOLDATOV:
Thank you, Justin.
Thank you, everybody
for having us.
As [INAUDIBLE] said
and Justin said,
we are the Russian
investigative journalists.
And we have been doing
this for almost 17 years.
We've focused on the
Russian Secret Services.
In the late 2000s,
we started off
investigating the change
in digital landscape
in the country.
And in 2012, it
became quite apparent
that the Kremlin got scared
of the internet, and mostly
because of the Arab Spring and
the Moscow protests on 2011,
2012.
So the Kremlin started a massive
offensive on internet freedoms
in our country.
IRINA BOROGRAN: Firstly, thank
you for inviting me here.
And as Andrei mentioned,
it was this time
when internet censorship was
introduced in Russia, became
a start for writing
our new book,
"The Red Web, The Kremlin's
War on the Internet,"
which was published in 2015
here in the United States.
But since 2015, there have
been many developments
in Russia and US
relationship, and notably
during the US election.
And we felt that it was very
important to write about this,
and to share what
we found by adding
a new chapter to the book.
And we called it, "The Red Web
Comes to the United States."
And it was published
this August.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: So
let's talk about how
censorship works in Russia.
Can you give me a little
bit of a sense of,
on a day to day basis, what the
experience of someone in Russia
is like as relates
to censorship?
ANDREI SOLDATOV:
Well, on the surface,
it looks like we
have all elements,
technological elements
of censorship.
We have an internet
filtering system.
We have lots of blacklists,
not one, of banned websites.
We have an extensive system
of online surveillance.
And it's extremely intrusive.
Actually, it's a
system of back doors
to all services in
our country provided
for the Russian Secret Services.
And we also have,
unfortunately, we
have people sent
to jail for posting
something sensitive or
critical of the Kremlin.
But at the same time,
it's quite clear
that this system technologically
is not very, I would say,
effective.
Internet filtering is porous.
For example, if you want to--
actually, believe that you need
to access a blocked website,
you can to use very simple
methods, simple tools.
You don't need even to use WIPI.
You can use Google Translate.
It also helps.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: Anyone from
Google Translate here today?
ANDREI SOLDATOV: I'll say hello.
And if you want to
communicate securely,
you still have this option.
You can use messengers.
So lots of them are
extremely popular in Russia.
And they turned to
a sort of new media.
But still, the system is
quite effective in silencing
people who want to talk
about things online openly.
And I think the idea
of the Kremlin approach
is to be based more on
intimidation than technology.
And actually, it's a
very Soviet approach.
When we researched
it for our book,
we checked how things
were organized back
in the Soviet times.
And one of the most
astonishing things we found out
is that the KGB as a
powerful security service
was technically
not very advanced.
And the head of
powers of the KGB,
it was capable of
eavesdropping on 300 phone
calls simultaneously.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN:
And 300 phone calls
at the same time, that was it.
That was the cap.
ANDREI SOLDATOV: Yeah.
That was 1991.
IRINA BOROGRAN: And everybody
was frightened by the KGB
in the Soviet times.
ANDREI SOLDATOV: So
actually, we know
how-- they knew how
to send a message,
but everybody should
be very, very cautious.
And it looks like they use
the same approach today.
We send a message.
We can pick up some
people, send them to jail.
And that would make [INAUDIBLE].
JUSTIN KOSSLYN:
And does that work?
When they send folks
to jail, whether it's
an activist, a journalist,
someone else, what happens?
IRINA BOROGRAN: It happens--
bloggers and users.
Because it's not
about journalists.
Journalists have not been
sent in jail in Russia.
But people found out
that they're in jail,
there are some kind of
protest in the cities
or mostly in Moscow.
And that's all.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: Are
those protests effective?
ANDREI SOLDATOV: No.
IRINA BOROGRAN: One times, it
was effective when a blogger--
one blogger who
went to the church
and played and
played Pokemon Go,
and then posted a
video on YouTube,
was sent to jail for this,
for posting this video,
because it is very, very
offensive for the Orthodox
Church in Russia.
And there is a special
article at the criminal court.
He was sent to jail.
It incited a lot of
protest on the internet,
on YouTube, everywhere,
and even on the street.
And after this protest, he was--
ANDREI SOLDATOV:
Released, actually.
IRINA BOROGRAN: He was bailed.
And he wasn't released, but
he's under house arrest now.
That's OK for him.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: So what are
people's views on censorship
in Russia?
Do people generally think
that this is a good system,
or they think it's a
bad system, or are they
just indifferent, they
accept it as a way of life?
IRINA BOROGRAN:
Beginning in 2012,
when the authorities introduced
this internet filtering
system in the country,
general public was not
very interested in this.
And we didn't notice any
attention to this issue.
We tried to attract a lot
of attention, but we failed.
But after then, few
years ago, the Kremlin
made two big mistakes.
The Kremlin blocked the
most popular torrent website
in the country.
And then they tried
to block PornHub.
After that even people who
have never been interested
in Russian politics,
or in politics at all,
started learning how to
use circumvention tools.
ANDREI SOLDATOV:
And actually Russia,
in a week after this biggest
Russian torrents website
was blocked--
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: You
mean BitTorrent,
the legal file-sharing service?
ANDREI SOLDATOV: Yeah.
So almost immediately,
in a week,
Russia skyrocketed to
the second position
in the number of Tor users.
Now, we are second only
to the United States.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: Tor, the
anonymous routing browser?
ANDREI SOLDATOV:
Yes, this famous VPN
which is provided for free.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: Got it.
So as long as they don't
go after your illegal file
sharing or your
pornography, it's all good.
But once they cross those
lines, people got agitated.
ANDREI SOLDATOV: Absolutely.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN:
Has there been any,
on the political side, any
mobilization or any cases
where anyone has
engaged in the same way?
ANDREI SOLDATOV:
Yeah, I think so.
Because initially, the
idea of internet filtering
was sold to the public on the
pretext of protecting children
against pedophiles,
and against people
who spread suicidal notes,
something really strange.
But people accepted this
because it's all about children.
But five years passed.
And now everybody understood
it's not about children.
It's about politics.
And this year, we got three
protests, actually, in Moscow.
We got marches.
We got big events.
And the Russian Pirate Party
organized some of these events.
And we got thousands
of people protesting.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: The
Russian Pirate Party?
ANDREI SOLDATOV: Yes.
It's a very popular
thing in terms
of they actually
monitor a lot of things
about internet censorship.
And also, they're trying to
organize some things offline.
And the latest protest
was really huge.
It was about
thousands of people.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN:
That's very cool.
Isn't the Pirate Party
running Iceland, incidentally?
ANDREI SOLDATOV: Exactly.
It's a big aspiration for all
branches of the Pirate Party
everywhere.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: Very cool.
So turning to
technology a little bit,
is there anything you can share?
You mentioned
earlier that there is
this technological
censorship regime in Russia.
But it sounds like it's
only effective to a point.
Why is that?
ANDREI SOLDATOV: Well, I think
that the problem is that when
you have the internet in a
country built almost 20 years
without any kind of intrusion
from the government--
and that was the case for Russia
for almost 20 years from 1991
to 2011--
it's extremely difficult
technologically
to add this element of
censorship and filtering.
You need to redesign or redefine
the entire infrastructure
of the internet.
It's extremely difficult, as the
Russian authorities found out.
Last year, they even tried
to enlist some support
from the Chinese.
And the Chinese went to Moscow,
said, we're happy to help.
But you need to get rid
of all American equipment.
The problem is that it's really
difficult. You cannot replace,
say, in one day, all Cisco
in such a big country with
something produced in China.
So that's why now,
they're trying
to find a way how to remodel
the critical infrastructure
of the internet in Russia.
But it's very tricky.
And I don't see any
successes so far.
IRINA BOROGRAN: In fact,
the Russian authorities
were frightened to replace
the American equipment
by the Chinese equipment.
Chinese offered to put into
the system Huawei equipment.
And that was frightening for
the Russian security services,
because they are
suspicious to Chinese.
ANDREI SOLDATOV: Chinese, yeah.
IRINA BOROGRAN: So it's
also an advantage for us.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN:
Well, I don't think
you need to convince
a room of Googlers
that doing a whole-scale
infrastructure swap out
is going to be
technologically hard.
How about on the sort
of consumer side?
You guys are individual actors.
You don't have the
resources of a large player.
How do you use
technology in your work?
Is it a force for good?
Is it a hindrance?
What are your thoughts on that?
IRINA BOROGRAN: Without
technology, we just
wouldn't be who we are.
Because we set up our website
agentura.ru back in 2000.
And we were young journalists.
We didn't have any money to pay
for printing house, for paper.
But we spent a little money
for maintaining our websites.
And it still cost us very cheap.
So we can do--
we can continue doing our work.
ANDREI SOLDATOV: And
also, actually, it's
extremely important for us
because, for many reasons,
it's now become really difficult
to find a place for publishing
your stories in the country.
It's not a coincidence that
we have both of our books,
and the first was
published in 2010,
it was all about the
Russian Secret Services,
and the second one, "Red Web."
And both of them, we published
it first in the United States.
But to communicate
with our publisher,
of course you need technology.
And thanks to Skype and Google
Hangout, while you can--
you might be in Moscow,
still communicating
with your editors
and publishers, which
is a great thing.
And also, of course, it helps
us to gather information
and intelligence,
in a way, because we
can use all kinds of
things like data mining.
And now it's extremely
important in Russia.
You can use all these databases.
And you can find some
really exposing stuff.
Like some years ago,
thanks to one database,
we found out that now we
have in Russia not one system
of online surveillance mentioned
by one security service,
but eight of them.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: Eight different
systems of online surveillance?
ANDREI SOLDATOV: Yes,
built simultaneously
by eight agencies.
And we just found it out
thanks to data mining.
Because officially, you cannot
get any comments from these
agencies, because it's
considered to be state secret.
And sometimes,
technologies which
were not meant to be
used by journalists
prove to be extremely
helpful, for example, drones.
And some years ago, I think
it was seven years ago,
Irina had a very
big investigation
about the luxury
villas which were
given for free to the FSB
Russian Security Services
generals.
And I think at that
time, you never
thought that you can
actually approach this.
IRINA BOROGRAN: It wasn't
possible to approach.
I got information.
I checked all documents.
It was clear that these
generals just grabbed
state real estate for free.
And I had now a chance to
approach to this real estate
and take a picture.
Because it was very well guarded
by the security services.
And it was hidden under a
huge fence-- no chances.
But now, I can do this
easily to launch a drone.
ANDREI SOLDATOV: Actually, we
got some interesting things
available on YouTube.
It's mostly done by
a Russian opposition
leader, Navalny's team.
And they got this team
of-- and they can actually
launch drones all the time.
In the most recent
example, they just--
I think it was three weeks
ago-- they exposed and used
secret luxury villa
renovated specifically
for Putin's personal use.
And it's crazy footage.
You can see everything.
And it's amazing.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: And it's
on YouTube, you say.
ANDREI SOLDATOV: Exactly.
IRINA BOROGRAN: It's on YouTube.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: So you
mentioned that there
are eight different agencies.
Can you give a little bit more
color on the kind of things
that they're looking at?
You said earlier that they're
filtering internet stuff.
But with eight
different agencies,
is that all they're doing, or
are there other activities?
ANDREI SOLDATOV:
No, of course, they
have other activities to do.
But they have the
right to conduct
these kinds of operations.
So because now, we had
this climate in Russia
where actually, if
you ask for some funds
for the secret
services, all is fine.
Vladimir Putin is very happy
to provide these funds.
So these agencies just
use it as an opportunity
to build their own systems
of online surveillance.
The tricky thing about this
surveillance, which is it's
not like mass surveillance,
because there still
some technical problems for
the Russian secret services.
Especially, for
example, they do not
know how to build
huge databases.
They still rely on American
technologists like Oracle.
To be honest, even the
internal database of the FSB
is built on Oracle.
So they do not know
how to do those things.
So instead of mass
surveillance, they
do targeted surveillance, which
means that they need first
to know who should be spied on.
And then they start the thing.
But in a way, it's extremely
effective in making the IT
industry in Russia complicit
in these activities.
Because what
actually it means, it
means that if you are small
or big internet service
provider, in Moscow
or in any town,
you need to get a license.
And one of the things
in this license
is you are required to
install a special equipment,
so-called black box, which
is actually a backdoor.
For that, you need to get
a plan of implementation
from the local
branch of the FSB.
And actually, it
means that you need
to get along with these guys.
And you are provided
a contact number.
So a guy from the local
branch could always call you
and ask for some favors.
And also, you have
physically a cable
which connects your service with
the local branch of the FSB.
And you know nothing
about what actually
is intercepted on your services,
because it's all state secret.
And you have no
security clearance.
As ISP, you have no
access, sometimes, even
to the room where you
have his black box.
So it's actually a back door,
but also it's a phone number.
So you might be, one day asked
to shut down some website
or maybe to look into
someone's email accounts,
and to provide it to
the FSB as a favor.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: How do
they decide who to target?
IRINA BOROGRAN:
That's complicated.
In fact, they have
to combat crimes.
But aside crimes, now
they monitor environment
in a particular region
or in Moscow, say,
and just to choose the victim.
Usually, mostly,
this is a person
who was known for his or
her political activity
or some opposition activity, or
publishing something critical
of the Kremlin.
And when they are
designated as a target,
they started to monitor all
his activity on the internet.
And this is enough for--
sometimes it's enough for
sentence him or her to prison.
Let me give one example.
One guy was sent to
prison for two years
only for posting on his page
on social network of VKontakte,
which is modeled after Facebook,
the most popular in Russia,
pictures of toothpaste,
of a tube of toothpaste.
And sentence was like this--
"squeeze Russia
out of yourself."
He got two years in prison.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: Sorry,
I don't understand.
It was a toothpaste that
said "squeeze Russia out
of yourself?"
ANDREI SOLDATOV: Yeah.
IRINA BOROGRAN: Toothpaste and
squeeze Russia out of yourself.
That's Russophobic.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: What is
it even saying, though?
What does it mean?
ANDREI SOLDATOV: Well,
nobody actually understands.
IRINA BOROGRAN:
There was an allusion
to some saying of
Russian writer Chekhov,
that means you need to--
ANDREI SOLDATOV: Squeeze
a slave out of you.
IRINA BOROGRAN: Squeeze
the slave from yourself.
But at the same time,
it's really stupid.
It doesn't--
JUSTIN KOSSLYN:
What does it mean?
It means it got him
two years in prison.
ANDREI SOLDATOV: Yes.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: Wow.
Have you had near brushes with
those kind of experiences?
ANDREI SOLDATOV:
Well we, as I said,
we started many years ago, I
think it was 2000, 1999, 2000.
And of course, back then--
actually, it started
very early for us.
Early in 2002, we got the very
first criminal investigation
against us.
And sometimes it's
really, I would say--
well, you feel really nervous.
Because these interrogations,
they are conducted in a prison,
actually--
just by chance.
So you never know what
might happen to you next.
And maybe you would stay
there, or maybe not.
It's a big question.
But I would say that if--
well, if you tried to
understand how things changed,
I would say that
today, the tactics
became much more subtle.
So back then, it was
mostly about targeting
individual journalists.
And now, it's about how to
deal with editors and owners
of the media, which results in
the situation when you cannot
find a place to get
your stuff published.
And you cannot say, look,
in a way, it's worse.
Because when you have someone--
well, a journalist--
targeted by the Kremlin,
it means at least
with journalists,
could apply to public.
He might make his case
public, and say, look, I'm
a victim of this
kind of pressure.
But now, it'll all a kind
of management problem.
It's between you
and your editor.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: Right.
It's the same philosophy
where there is the cable,
but there's also
the phone number.
ANDREI SOLDATOV: Right.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: And
it's all kind of done--
ANDREI SOLDATOV: It's manual.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN:
Yeah, very manual.
It's a good way
to think about it.
And you mentioned
earlier that your book
was published in the US.
It was published
here before Russia?
Is that correct?
ANDREI SOLDATOV: Yeah.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: Why is that?
ANDREI SOLDATOV: Because
Russian publishers,
they were not very--
they understood the risks.
And because it's a
long story for us,
so we started publishing
this stuff in the West,
maybe in 2010, 2009.
So we had experience.
And it's really interesting
that Russian publications, they
sometimes pick up
your stories, but only
after they're published by
the Western publications.
And they always ask to
maintain this byline
that first time, this was
published in English, in say,
"The Guardian."
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: OK.
ANDREI SOLDATOV: So it helps
them to shift responsibility,
and to say, look, it was
already published somewhere.
And the same goes
with the books.
So they say, well,
maybe, one day we
are happy to publish
your book, but first,
get them published in the West.
And actually that has happened.
We got our book finally
published in Russia,
but only after it was
published in the United States.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: So sort of a
boomerang, outside-in strategy.
ANDREI SOLDATOV: Yes.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: And I'm
actually surprised to hear
that you were able to publish
your book in Russia at all.
Why is that?
ANDREI SOLDATOV: Maybe
because the first book
became a bestseller, actually.
It actually made a lot of
money for the publisher.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: Congratulations.
ANDREI SOLDATOV: And not for us.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: Condolences.
ANDREI SOLDATOV: But it
was a really strange moment
in Russian history, because
it was September of 2011.
And the book was just published.
And the FSB was not very happy,
so they sent some letters.
Actually, they sent some people
to-- for some strange reason,
they decided to visit
the printing house.
Why?
I still don't know.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: So
security services
showed up at the
printing house in Russia.
ANDREI SOLDATOV: Yes, not at
the offices of the publisher,
but in the printing house,
and ask crazy questions, like,
who paid for the
printing of the book?
And everybody said,
OK, it's the publisher.
And we were really nervous.
But then we got these
Moscow protests.
So the FSB, very soon, they
had some other things to do.
They needed to deal with
this political crisis.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: And
did they ever come back
to the printing house?
ANDREI SOLDATOV: No, they
forgot about it completely.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN:
Hey, whatever works.
I guess it's all people.
And that's one of
the themes, I think
of the points you've
been making-- that there
is a technology element.
But it really is as much
manual as it is automatic.
ANDREI SOLDATOV: Absolutely.
Yeah.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: So looking
forward a little bit--
and we're going to
pause in a few minutes.
So if folks have questions as we
go, just be jotting them down.
And then we'll open it up
for any audience questions
momentarily.
But before we do
that, I just want
to turn to the
future a little bit.
Where do you see things going?
IRINA BOROGRAN: We
are journalists,
and we had to predict
future and always failed.
But even one things is
absolutely predictable--
that Vladimir Putin will be
the new Russian president
next year.
ANDREI SOLDATOV: Next year.
But I think that if you
try to see the whole thing,
maybe we still have
some source for hope.
Because it looks like
with the internet,
the Kremlin faces a
formidable challenge.
Because historically, the whole
Russian history, actually,
has been defined by
a hierarchical order.
We always had someone on the
very top calling the shots.
It was maybe the czar,
or maybe the emperor,
or maybe the leader of
the Communist Party.
But right now, we are
dealing with a situation
where we have the network,
which is, by definition,
a horizontal creature.
And it looks like the Kremlin
has some problems understanding
the nature of the network.
Just three years ago, we
had this excellent example.
There was a case against
this guy, Navalny,
and he was about
to be sent to jail.
And some of his people wanted
to mobilize people to protest.
So we launched a protest
group on Facebook.
And this group was immediately
taken down by Facebook
under the request of
the Russian government.
And immediately, we got
a lot of people outraged
by this story launching
their own pages,
asking people to get to a
particular place in Moscow.
And as a result, we
got tens of thousands
of people protesting
on the Moscow streets.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN:
Tens of thousands
of people spontaneously.
ANDREI SOLDATOV:
Spontaneously, just like that.
So I think these things
are still very difficult
for the Kremlin to understand.
And it gives us some hope.
IRINA BOROGRAN:
Putin still believes
that the internet is ruled
by some guys on the top,
and he said that it is the CIA.
ANDREI SOLDATOV: Yeah, actually.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: Really.
ANDREI SOLDATOV: Yeah,
he actually just--
IRINA BOROGRAN: He
said that the CIA--
that the internet
was a CIA creation.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: Hmm.
And in general, how do they
think about technology?
So that's one data point.
How do you think,
five years from now,
they'll be conceptualizing
the internet?
ANDREI SOLDATOV: Well, in our
business, and for the media,
it's all about social media.
And we already have
some interesting things.
But people tried to abandon
the idea of domain names
for the media.
Actually, they moved
to social media.
So they have some recent
project, [INAUDIBLE]
project, which was launched
solely on social media.
They have a page on Facebook,
a page on VKontakte,
and something on
medium.com, that's all.
And it's not only
because we believe
in the idea of social media, but
also because it's more secure.
Once you have a website
and a domain name,
it might be easily blocked.
You might get some visitors.
And if you have everything
based on social media,
that provides you
with some opportunity.
And simultaneously,
some people who
still believe in the
idea of domain names,
they think that now, maybe
it's time to move to Google.
Because it's also a big issue,
for say, for the country
or for dying regimes.
One thing is to block the
website of a particular media.
It's easy, especially if it's
Russian registered or it's--
But if it's based on-- it's
actually, physically on Google,
it means if you
want to block it,
you need to deal with
the whole Google.
And it's such a sensitive
thing for many that even
in the countries
of Central Asia--
and they're usually
not that subtle--
they're still hesitant.
And they do not know what to
do with this new phenomenon,
that many media might
be physically based
on Google services.
They just don't know how
to deal with this problem.
So maybe that
provides us, again,
some sense of, well,
maybe some sort of hope.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: Do you
foresee any changes
to the policies, or the laws,
or the enforcements around that?
ANDREI SOLDATOV:
Well, the problem
is that we have this problem--
the idea of localization.
The idea that--
I hate this term, but--
the balkanization
of the internet.
Unfortunately, it's such a
great idea for many, especially
in Russia and China.
They love the idea
of-- they brand it
as a digital sovereignty.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: [INAUDIBLE]?
ANDREI SOLDATOV: Sovereignty.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: Sovereignty,
digital sovereignty.
ANDREI SOLDATOV: And
basically, it's about borders.
Like, we have our territory.
And it's limited by borders.
We need to have exactly the
same thing on the internet.
And the idea is that if
you have some service--
it might be Facebook,
Twitter, anything,
Google-- you need
to have all servers.
We have the Russian, with this
particular country, citizens'
data on this territory, just
to be able to access it easily,
and to manipulate,
maybe, with this data.
And unfortunately,
it's a very I would
say appealing idea
to many, because it's
something about patriotism.
Yes, for example, we
were at some meeting
with the Russian officials
and they said very openly,
yes, we are very grateful
to the Americans.
They invented the whole thing.
But now it's time for
us to control our space.
It's about our sense
of a national state.
It's a great opportunity
for the security services
to get direct access
to users' data.
Because now, they
are able to spy
on the services located abroad.
Because they can't find
direct access to it.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: So
last question before we
turn to the audience--
overall, are you an optimist?
A pessimist?
Do you think that the internet
will be a force for good five,
10 years from now?
Or do you think we're sort of
in this unique window in history
that's going to close.
ANDREI SOLDATOV:
Well, you know, when
we started writing our book, our
American publisher said, look,
you need to add something
optimistic in the end
of your book.
Because otherwise,
why to read it?
And finally, we
thought wow, maybe
there is something in his idea.
But seriously, no,
we are optimists.
We believe that right now,
we have these opportunities.
We can publish very
sensitive stories,
and it's all thanks
to technology.
And it looks like
for the Kremlin,
they might know some tricks,
but it's really difficult for us
to catch up with
development of technologies.
And also, the problem is--
which also gives me some hope--
just this year, Vladimir
Putin signed a new information
security doctrine.
And it's essentially Soviet.
It actually has one thing,
that before introducing
some new technologies,
telecommunication companies
should first consult
with the secret services.
And we knew that actually,
back in the Soviet times,
that destroyed the
telecommunication market
in our country.
Because if you need to ask
someone who is wise enough
to think about security, well,
it just slows down everything.
And that gives us hope.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: How
does that give you hope?
That seems like a--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ANDREI SOLDATOV: Well, no.
It's more in terms of that
it would slow down the, say,
internet business
in our country.
But in terms of given the,
well, the forces of control
some new means, I
think now all this--
I would say for them, it's
just difficult to catch up.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: I see.
ANDREI SOLDATOV: They're
always a bit slow.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: I see.
It's evidence that the
mindset has not been evolving.
ANDREI SOLDATOV: Yeah.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: Got it.
ANDREI SOLDATOV: When
you need to choose what's
the most important thing--
the development of technology
or security-- and you
always choose security
that means that you
lose something very important.
We live in a world where
development of technology
is an essential thing.
And if you always trade it
for security or for the ghost
of security, you lose.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: Got it.
You can't-- it's not going
to be viable to keep up with
the international technology
scene if that's the approach.
What do you think, Irina?
IRINA BOROGRAN: I think
that Kremlin is always
losing to the technologies
because the Kremlin doesn't
understand the nature
of the internet.
And that is very
advantageous for us,
very good and big
advantage for us.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: Well,
thank you so much
for the work that you do,
for sharing it with us today,
and for taking the time
to answer these questions.
And I'll turn it over now.
But let's do a
round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
IRINA BOROGRAN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So speaking of
digital sovereignty,
what are your thoughts, and
what's the sentiment coming out
of Russia around the
"fake news" phenomenon
that has essentially determined
the elections of the US?
IRINA BOROGRAN:
Firstly, we don't
think that Russian fake
news determined that
as a result of the US election.
We believe that
Trump was elected
because of [INAUDIBLE] reasons.
And Americans wanted
to believe him.
But of course
there's this machine,
which produced fake
news, trolls, and so on,
to some extent effective,
and especially in terms
of disrupting discussion
on the internet
and to dissemination of cynicism
among the internet users.
What is the modus operandi
of the Kremlin in this era?
The armies of trolls are
spreading negative information
about everything, about
parties, about representatives
of different groups
of population,
about political leaders.
And it puts you in a
very vulnerable position.
You feel that you
can't believe anybody.
And so it doesn't matter who
will be your new president,
or maybe the old, strong leader
is better than any new leader.
That's what they're doing.
But I think that
they can oppose.
I mean, the democracy can oppose
to these things developing
good mass media, good quality
and progressive mass media.
That is the way how
it could be, how
we can combat these propaganda.
ANDREI SOLDATOV:
And maybe the thing
is, which we need to
understand, that this all
started in our country.
And firstly, the
first target was
Russian political opposition
and independent journalism.
And unfortunately, it was first
very successful in Russia,
mostly because we still are
a very confused society,
a post-soviet,
post-totalitarian society.
We have a lack of
trust in anything,
especially in
political institutions.
And it left you,
when you think of it,
it left you with
the idea that you
have the general public, the
population, and the leader,
and that's all--
nothing in between.
And that was used by
the Kremlin to the full.
Because in this case, you think
this guy, he's strong enough.
We know who he is.
And we do not know
all other guys.
So it's better to
keep with this guy.
And it looks like
Putin just tried
to export this idea
of complete distrust
in institutions to
the United States.
I do not believe
that it was born,
it was invented by Putin here.
I mean, you already
had some basis
for this kind of mistrust in
the establishment, in the media.
So what they tried to do, they
tried to exploit this feeling.
They added some fuel.
And unfortunately, it was,
well, successful to some degree.
As a journalist, I'm a bit
skeptical that it completely
changes the game.
But of course, we
added some fuel.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: So if I'm
hearing you right, just
to summarize, it was
as much about changing
the level of overall
trust in our society
over a long period
of time as it was
about any particular election.
IRINA BOROGRAN: Yes.
IRINA BOROGRAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
kind of on the same lines.
So I was at the Oxford Internet
Institute back in 2010,
kind of studying the beginnings
of computational propaganda.
And today, I have friends
who are journalists
at NBC, big news outlets, who
are being tasked with covering
these types of things.
And I get questions from them,
like, is this actually real?
And so considering that--
and this is their job--
and so considering that
you've seen this in Russia
many times in terms of
disinformation campaigns,
are there any trends that
you've seen of evolve in Russia
that you think could
make the leap to the US?
ANDREI SOLDATOV: Well, to be
honest it looks like they--
it started in the West in
2014, mostly, and because
of the annexation of Crimea.
And firstly, the first
target was Ukraine.
And it was easier, because
we share the same language,
the same prejudices, the
same theories about how
we feel about the
West, and our history.
So you can play the same
tricks for the Russian
and for Ukrainians.
Then they tried something
in Eastern Europe.
To some extent, it was really
successful, once again,
because lots of people
in Eastern Europe
feel a bit, I would
say, fooled by the West.
They were promised a lot
and it was never delivered.
And finally, they tried
in the United Kingdom.
And they tried through
"The Guardian."
And they immediately
got spotted,
so it was not a
big success, mostly
for some language problems.
And of course, it was
mostly because people
who, back then, were hired
to do these kind of things,
were Russians, based
in Saint Petersburg
and some other places.
But unfortunately,
it's evolved with time.
And now, it looks like
they got some people
based in these countries who
are at least partly natives.
So they know how
to speak and how
to address the issues
which are really
important for this
particular region
or this particular district.
And they use this kind of thing.
Still, I do not believe
that it's that effective.
But what makes them particularly
crucial in the Kremlin's
propaganda thing, that we
have this strange distinction,
that we have the Russian
bureaucracy, which is,
by definition, extremely slow.
And it's not only
about Foreign Ministry.
It's also about
Russian television.
It's also about Secret
Services to some degree.
But also, we've got
informal actors.
We have people who
officially have nothing
to do with the government.
And on the one hand, it
gives the Kremlin a sense
that they always could deny
responsibility in what we
do all the time, but also it
makes these groups much more
flexible and adventurous.
Because they, unlike
the bureaucracy,
they have direct
access to the Kremlin.
And they can always
ask, look, is it
fine we do that, or maybe
next day we can try these?
So it's actually we
are dealing with a very
flexible and adventurous
community of people
who are really committed
to do these things.
Because actually, the risks
are still very low for them.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: So I
guess the answer is,
it's gotten harder to tell.
ANDREI SOLDATOV: Yeah.
IRINA BOROGRAN:
Anything to add, Irina?
IRINA BOROGRAN: No.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: Anything
you want to add?
ANDREI SOLDATOV: No.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: OK.
Please.
AUDIENCE: It's somewhat
ironic that today
is Putin's 65th birthday.
And as "The Economist"
published this morning,
he has no intention
of stepping down,
as I think you pointed out.
And of course, this article,
which just this morning
was, of course,
talking about Navalny.
And so I guess two parts of the
question from your perspective
is, what is his future,
Navalny's, given
how much of an uproar he's
made, particularly in the West?
You know he's on "60
Minutes" a handful of times.
So where is he
going, or is he not?
And then where-- because a
lot of I think what he's done
has been to catalyze somewhat
of the youth, and millennials,
and younger people.
So what role will younger people
play in the next five years?
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: And
actually, it might even
be worth just giving a bit of
quick context for the group
on who he is and
the work he's done.
IRINA BOROGRAN: Navalny is
an opposition politician
who adopted a new way of
doing politics in Russia.
As you know, today in Russia,
opposition politicians
can now access to the media--
traditional mass media, TV
channels, radio stations,
and newspapers, and
they could use website--
because all-- most of them are
under the Kremlin's control
or under the control of
pro-Kremlin oligarchs.
So he started to gain popularity
doing [INAUDIBLE] on that.
He set up a special
channel on YouTube.
There's another
He started-- in fact, he started
with Twitter, and YouTube
channel, and his own websites.
And three years ago, he
got a lot of popularity,
which was even bigger.
It became bigger in 2017 for
I don't know what reasons.
Maybe because of
a financial crisis
in Russia and bad
economic situation.
Maybe because the authoritative
regime became stronger
than it was, than it used to be.
But his videos usually get
millions of viewers, tens,
in fact, tens of
millions viewers.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: Tens of millions
of viewers on a single YouTube
video.
ANDREI SOLDATOV: Yeah,
so that's a great thing.
And when we had the last
mass protest in Moscow,
Navalny was arrested.
But any case, we got--
there were tens of thousands
of people on the streets.
And many of them were
students, and even schoolboys
and schoolgirls.
That was really
unusual for Russians,
because previously, we've
seen only people who's
older than 20.
ANDREI SOLDATOV: And maybe,
answering your question,
the interesting thing now
is that previously, Navalny
based all his activity online.
It was always about
something online.
And right now, he started
building his network offline.
And surprisingly,
it's quite successful.
When we got the latest
protest, Navalny
tried to organize and to
enlist people in the regions.
And we got protests in 80 towns.
Which is really--
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: 80?
ANDREI SOLDATOV: 80.
So it's really big, because
there's a usual theory
and a traditional theory
about the Russian political
opposition is, yes, you
have some people voting
for you in big towns, but the
rest of Russia doesn't care.
And they support Putin.
It's not the case now.
It's a big, new development.
And I think he will invest more
and more resources, and more
of his time, and of
his people's time,
into trying to build his
network in the regions.
And as I said, that's
quite effective.
It's really
interesting what might
happen to him and to his
ideas, when he actually
started this move, this
shift from the online world
to the offline world.
Of course, there
are some problems,
because it's a very
traditional way
of building a
political party, which
means that you need
to be ready to answer
some traditional questions,
like what you think
about the economic situation,
political situation,
I don't know,
Crimea, many things.
And he is not that ready.
But still, there
is some potential.
IRINA BOROGRAN:
At the moment, he
is in the detention
center, was detained
two days ago for 20 days.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN: Thank you.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: In the
beginning of your talk,
you mentioned that there
are very few things that
could resonate with
the general public
when it comes to censorship.
Do you feel like there is
a cultural shift happening
in Russian society, where
people are starting to respect
open freedom of speech more?
Or is it still mostly about
just accessing the BitTorrents
and pornography?
This is one thing.
And another thing, the topic of
our talk today, surveillance,
censorship and
beyond, and I wanted
to ask you a little bit
about the beyond part.
Do you feel like part of the
strategy of the government when
it comes to
censorship is to make
the community
complacent with it,
doing it through the
idea of censorship
being necessary to control the
country, to fight terrorism,
and to make sure Russia
grows in a stable fashion?
ANDREI SOLDATOV: I will try to--
it's actually the
interesting thing,
but there is a way to answer
both of your questions.
And one, it looks
like five years ago,
when they introduced
this system,
they're trying to
play some tricks,
like we are protecting children.
We are doing things.
They're actually
just doing exactly
the same thing that was first
introduced by the British.
So in a way, they imitate
the British approach
to internet filtering.
And it looks like
some years ago,
actually two years
ago, they completely
abandoned all pretenses.
Now, it's even not
about terrorists.
It's about the West.
We have the West.
They are plotting against us.
We need to fight back.
We need to protect us.
And unfortunately, this
idea is accepted by many.
And even the ideas
of complete reshuffle
of the infrastructure
in the country
is sort of accepted by many.
Because the internet is seen as
an invention of the Americans.
So we need to fight back.
For example, there was a crazy
story just two years ago,
how the idea of
data localization
was sold to Russia.
Some Russian officials
sat from the stage
that actually, you can see
in Crimea, some of the people
are playing Warcraft.
They were-- now, they are
not capable of playing,
because they are cut
off by the Americans.
So we need to do
something about it.
And on this kind of
pretext, well, unfortunately
are quite popular.
And people accept this idea.
IRINA BOROGRAN: And second
question, of course I
think that it always started
with something nonpolitical
like torrents websites
and pornography.
And this has shifted
very soon to politics,
because to block pornography
websites is also politics.
It's a restriction.
JUSTIN KOSSLYN:
Thank you all again.
Thank you.
ANDREI SOLDATOV: Thank you.
IRINA BOROGRAN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]